earlier you mentioned havana syndrome
and when i looked into it i found it to
be terribly murky i don't know what
havana syndrome is and so when you're
this is in reference to my research on
you with regard to skinwalker and then
you said that well we can classify some
people savannah syndrome i want to know
firstly what is havana syndrome how are
you able to
classify them as that it seems like a
cloudy definition and then also
you concluded that some of if not all of
what was happening at skinwalker from
what you've studied with state actors so
i don't know what is meant by state
actors and how you came to that
conclusion so there are a couple of
questions right there yeah so um okay so
um
right so this all started of course with
uh with kit
uh and you know there's he's actually
given a
uh an interview i think it was on the
debrief or somewhere recently uh that's
very in-depth about um
sort of the history of the of the
project and the timeline
um
so
when we first were looking at these
patients that
we got this basically a bucket of cases
um
from the
basically the defense uh intelligence
axis
that the doctors didn't know what to do
with people who were
in distress nobody would nobody could
figure out what it is that was going
wrong with them and so kit at some point
was called in on on some of them
um
so
the the reason why many of these cases
are murky
and is actually hidden
in a way in the term syndrome
a syndrome
is usually a
medical terminology for something which
has
uh that has related
but disparate symptomologies
so usually it's like there's 20 things
that can fall within this classification
system you're hearing buzzing headaches
this and that
and you don't have to have all of them
you just have to have enough of them
and you say you've got this syndrome we
don't but usually what people are
thinking when they say syndrome is that
there's probably multiple different
uh sub pathologies within them each of
which is a distinct and unique group so
for instance 100 years ago or even 80
years ago
you could have cancer and cancer broadly
is
a you know is actually
has about you know 200 different
diseases underneath it
all right blood cancer you know calling
etc etc
so
um we actually in the by around 2015
2016 we're calling it what we called at
the time or i should say kit
interference syndrome
that people were being interfered with
and here were the range of
things that were happening
to them
uh and so what as a doctor you do you
basically you start to
determine what the individual symptoms
are
and those individual symptoms then are
matched to definitions
in what's the best way to do it is
called the icd codes
right and so um
the icd codes are
classification
system of diseases
and related health problems right so you
have you have this kind of a skin uh
blistering uh it's you know and it has
these you know it has infiltration of
macrophages and this and this it's icd
code x
and so what you what he does is he he
takes the the the verbal testimony or
his observations of the patient
and you know writes down these icd codes
and it's a way of just classifying and
knowing that you're talking about apples
to apples oranges to oranges
kind of a thing um
and then right around 2018 or so the
so-called havana
cases were coming up which were
which havana cuba specifically some of
the diplomatic personnel were having
these buzzing sounds getting sick
headaches
etc
and uh
and that kind of went public and then
kit got a hold of some of the case files
um related to to these some of these
events and realized that the the when he
matched the icd codes
of the havana syndrome they matched or
overlapped with a lot of our cases
right
um
and then uh
after that
um i'm gonna put you uh
a thing here somebody actually put it in
twitter somewhere to remind me of it um
a uh
a science
group the so-called jasons which are a
group of you know scientists who the
government calls upon i'm not part of
the jason's
to um help them
uh understand
the
um
you know some event that occurs and
write white papers and things like that
they were brought in to basically do an
assessment
of this and it became um
obvious that
these cases were
probably
driven by
some i used the term state actor some
people got bent out of shape because i
used that term i just meant
yeah what does it mean
it basically means you know
somebody who is an agent of let's say
russia or china or something like that
or a rogue element within our own
government or frankly you know i mean
state actor implies some sort of uh
you know funded by
uh uh a government
um
but it could just as easily be
you know
terrorist groups
who gained acts who gained access to
um
you know some of these technologies that
could cause these things and if you look
at that
pdf that i just sent you there's
uh all kinds of different approaches
acoustic attacks electromagnetic attacks
uh microwave i'll include a link to that
in the description as well yeah um
and uh so it's it's not it's not beyond
the capability of anybody in the last 20
years
to have these kinds of
attack
uh you know approaches vectors or
whatever
um so
so when i say it's out of my hands
uh when it's is is that well these are
clearly falling under
a um
a uh
what's the right word um it's falling
under the rubric or an umbrella
of something which appears to be purely
human or terrestrial yeah with intention
with intention and has nothing to do
with uaps whatsoever now what's
interesting is and this is what the
whoever it was who tweeted this
recently
um
i haven't found the number in here i'm
gonna have to go in but they said about
10 to 15 of the cases
uh that the jason's had looked at could
not be explained under the rubric of
havana syndrome and were as as of yet
um on
of indeterminate causation
that doesn't mean that they're uap
right it just means that again the the
broad bucket of
people with strange things happening to
them uh
didn't fall under that now
there's already people out there trying
to pick apart
the things that lou has been talking
about with injury and the things that
kit talked about as injury actually i
actually spoke with lou about it um the
other day
some of the cases that lou was talking
about are different
than the um ones that uh kid are talking
about so just because kit says
it's you know he's got them all figured
out
um
and uh it doesn't mean that
there aren't other cases out there that
lou is aware of
that are different than the ones that
kit is that have a much more proximal
let's say
uap relationship
but even kit and i talk with him about
it
fairly
frequently
is like well look i can explain it by
human technology i don't need to invoke
something else
right
but he's very careful in how he parses
his word i can explain it doesn't say it
was caused by
human technology you know at the end of
the day a burn is a burn whether it's
caused by
you know
uh
an alien power generator or
you know the back end of a jet flame
right um so
you know he's just saying i don't need
the the fact that these injuries occur
does is not a smoking gun
for uap
so you know he's being a good scientist
about it
but the the only thing that you have to
sort of walk away from with it is some
of the people say
that the proximal cause
was an object that showed up
it wasn't they were working in their
office at the you know at the havana you
know american
embassy and they got headaches you know
these were people who were in the field
who saw something and something happened
to them the cash laundromat case is
probably one of the best
in
cases in point
i went through this recently released
dirt document from 2009 the dirt
document that i'm referencing is called
the defense intelligence reference
document it's titled anomalous acute and
sub-acute field effects on human
biological tissues you can find a link
to it in the description
i went through this recently released
dirt document from 2009 went through it
not with a fine-tooth comb with a
regular comb let's say
i skimmed it and i want to read a
passage to you and i want to know what
you make of it it said based on
historical cases humans have been found
to be injured from the exposures to
anomalous vehicles especially airborne
and when in relatively close proximity
and then i said okay especially airborne
which to me implies that there are some
non-airborne cases so what are these
non-airborne type vehicles and what's
the difference between the effects on
the witnesses from non-airborne versus
airborne uh i i don't know the specifics
that are being discussed there um
you know
non-airborne i don't know maybe it's the
thing is landed
i i don't know i don't know the
individual cases unfortunately
um
and uh
again it's um
i i can't pry them out of out of kit
for good reason
uh
for all the reasons that you you know he
just he just can't let these cases out
it doesn't have anything to do with uap
it says i i i couldn't force this stuff
i i can't force the information out of
some of the cancer patients for some of
the cancer patients that the doctors i
work with because they're rightly
protecting their privacy
you know people have great questions but
they think
they think that uh
we can just play
you know
willy-nilly with people's private data
you can't and it is i'm not hiding
behind it i'm telling you as much as
what i know
but um at the end of the day the
specifics
uh will remain
you know uh out of reach
i think the
what people should take away from it is
that it's it's reason to attempt to fund
true research
what we would call prospective
research
uh prepare to collect the data
in you know in a going forward manner as
opposed to retrospective analysis of old
cases where you're you're trying to
piece together something that happened
in the distant past
you prefer perspective i prefer
perspective now retrospective i mean we
do retrospective studies all the time on
cancer you know we with a large enough
cohort of individuals of colorectal
cancer for instance we can use
you know biological analyses of the of
the tissue and find signatures of
outcome
right because
retrospective we know what the we know
what the
disease was we know what the drug that
they were given and we know what the
outcome was for those patients and so
now what you're doing is you're looking
amongst the patients who had a good
outcome versus those that had a bad
outcome and saying was there a was there
a tissue structure that predicted the
good outcome or the bad outcome because
that tissue structure was going to be
susceptible to the drug
right to make the drug be more likely to
operate and work than not
and so that's just that's how these
prospective
now a prospective study would be i'm
setting up to do this and i'm going to
collect the data knowingly and i'm going
to create inclusion exclusion criteria
that bring the right kinds of patients
in and then i so i know i'm working with
apples and apples
right so
you you work with retrospective usually
to form hypotheses
interesting of what it is that you want
to do and then you prove the
retrospective
conclusions
uh with a prospective new study that's
tailored specifically to look at the
things that you think
are important